no one is applying 60ps and rubbing
their hands together and patting it in I
don't think I'm even exaggerating when I
say clean beauty is literally killing
people here is a little known fact about
mineral sunscreens a lot of them
actually contain unregulated chemical
sunscreens which isn't always a big
problem but it also kind of is I'm
Michelle chemistry pear tree cosmetic
chemist and massive sunscreen nerd and
today we're talking about inactive
ingredients in sunscreens that aren't
really inactive it's not that easy to
make a sunscreen it might seem like all
that's important in a sunscreen are the
active ingredients after all they're
listed separately on a label in the US
and Australia and the percentages are
right there but if you just mix these
ingredients into a base you probably
won't get SPF 50. that's because how
these are distributed in the rest of the
sunscreen is really important to how
well the sunscreen blocks UV that's why
sunscreen is one of the most difficult
products to formulate lots of things
like the other ingredients and how them
mixed together can make a really big
difference it's one of the reasons why
it can be hard to predict the SPF of the
sunscreen just from the active
ingredient percentages which I've talked
about before in my video on SPF testing
one cosmetic chemist told me it took her
six months to update an existing SPF 30
sunscreen to make it up to SPF 50 as
well as changing the levels of the
active ingredients she also had to
change a whole bunch of the inactive
ingredients as well and that's just to
update a sunscreen making a sunscreen
from scratch would take even longer so
there are a bunch of inactive
ingredients out there that can help the
actives in the sunscreen work better to
get you a higher SPF these are commonly
called SPF boosters a lot of these
really are just helping out the proper
sunscreen actives some are film formers
and solvents that help keep the
sunscreen actors spread out in an even
film on your skin it's a bit like a
smooth pay versus one that isn't mixed
up well if the coverage isn't even you
end up with gaps in the paint layer so
analogy time it's like a 4 football team
spreading out in front of the goalie
some boosters change the way the UV
travels in the sunscreen film for
example there are particles that bounce
the UV around for longer in the
sunscreen film so it has more of a
chance to get absorbed so I guess this
is like your football players getting
better at deflecting the ball but some
of them actually function just like
chemical sunscreens they absorb UV light
and convert it to other forms of energy
like heat exactly like a chemical
sunscreen so this is just like dumping a
whole bunch of extra players onto your
field which is illegal in football I
think take butyloft or salicylate it's
usually branded as a solvent or an
emollient moisturizer and it does do
these things but it does a lot more than
that here is a structure and here is the
structure of octa-salate the official
name for octa-salate is ethylhexyl
salicylate which as you can tell from
the name is butylactic salicylates
relative but is it a twin brother or a
distant cousin three times removed well
the first part of the name tells you how
many carbon atoms are attached to this
right part of the structure there are
four more carbons in butaloctal
salicylate if you know a bit of
chemistry or if you've watched my video
on how sunscreens work you'll know that
the section that absorbs UV is not the
bit that's different it's this
salicylate part on the left hand side
with the ring that absorbs the UV light
and it's identical in both molecules the
bit that's different doesn't actually
interact with UV at all this is what the
absorbent Spectra look like they both
protect against UV around the same so
butyluctosalicylate is really just
octa-salate's identical twin brother
with slightly longer hair functionally
and in every other relevant way really
they are the same thing they both
protect against UV around the same and
octa-sala can also act as a solvent and
moisturizing emollient so why isn't
butylactic salicylate classified as a
proper sunscreen active ingredient
radiant and put in that chopped box with
the percentage shown well it seems like
the manufacturer just decided not to go
through the proper legal process
sunscreen actors in most regions are
regulated in a special way this includes
in the EU where sunscreens are
technically Cosmetics but approved
sunscreen actors are included in a
special list in the regulations getting
a chemical sunscreen ingredient or any
sunscreen active registered means you
have to go through a special process
this involves submitting a whole bunch
of safety data for Regulators to assess
and based on that they decide if it's
going to be approved if there are any
special conditions of use so for example
if it could be used in sprays or lip
balms if it needs a warning label if
there's special grades allowed and what
the maximum percentage allowed should be
getting the safety data as well as the
whole process of registration can be
very expensive and it takes many years
if you look at the reports for MCE or
Mexico 400 which was officially approved
in the EU in 2020 some of their safety
data that they submitted is almost 10
years old now maybe you might be
thinking all this admin seems kind of
unnecessary why is there all this red
tape well these processes are in place
for a reason to ensure that everyone
stays safe if you buy a random sunscreen
from a store and use it you want to be
reasonably confident that you won't
massively poison yourself or get
sunburned using it before drug
regulation became a thing in the early
1900s people would get really sick or
even die from taking medications you'd
have medicines with opium and alcohol in
them even baby medicines which I guess
at least would make people feel better
for a bit this is the whole reason that
pretty much every country has some sort
of drug regulation and within the
regulations of the regions that I looked
at if you're using an ingredient in a
sunscreen to absorb UV and protect the
skin from that UV you are meant to
register it so from a legal perspective
butaloctal salicylate probably should
have been registered as a proper
sunscreen active so why hasn't anyone
done anything about this I honestly
don't know in Germany and Switzerland
it's been pointed out as a problem
before by government agencies but then
nothing actually happened so is this a
problem using it is really widespread
and accepted in Industry tons of brands
have it in their sunscreens from
multinational Brands down to really
small Brands who probably don't even
realize it's in their products I think
that's because butylactyl salicylate is
probably quite safe most of the time
after Starlight is generally considered
one of the safest sunscreen ingredients
and given how similar this is you would
expect the safety profile to be pretty
similar in most places you're allowed up
to five or ten percent after sale 8 I
didn't see any justification for how
they came up with this but ultrasalate
hasn't been officially flagged since
butyl luctosalicylate is recommended at
two to ten percent so it seems like most
of the time the total amount of these
two combined probably stays under 10 so
to me it seems like it's probably not a
huge issue for us as sunscreen users for
people allergic to salicylates it might
be an issue if they don't check their
native ingredients but more of an issue
is the lack of a dose limit because it
isn't regulated butylactyl salicylate is
probably safe at a similar dose to
optosolate but I suspect that some of
these mineral sunscreens that are using
really small amounts of zinc oxide and
titanium dioxide might be using a fair
Shake more butyloft than is recommended
and that could potentially be unsafe but
it is hard to tell just from the
ingredients list how much is being used
and whether the formulators are being
responsible and that is just one of the
risks of not having proper approval but
what I do have a massive gripe with is
brands that put butyloft salicylate in
their 100 mineral sunscreens while
bashing chemical sunscreens butyloft
salicylate is basically just after Sala
but less safe because it doesn't have
these extra safety precautions that come
with a properly approved sunscreen
ingredient like having performed safety
studies having a regulator go through
the safety studies to work out the
conditions for using it safely having a
limit on how much you can put into a
product having to declare the percentage
having assays done to check batches of
raw materials coming in and whether
they're stable in the final formula and
I could go on and all of this really
highlights a common problem with clean
Beauty called regrettable substitution
they demonize particular ingredients for
being toxic based on misinformation and
misinterpretation of studies which I
have talked about before but these
ingredients were used in products for a
reason they have a function it is really
difficult maybe even impossible to
formulate a 100 mineral sunscreen that
gives High SPF while also it being nice
and texture and not sticky no white cast
not drying so now that the clean brands
have scared potential customers about
chemical sunscreens they can't use them
and sunscreens are one of the few
products where there is a very clear
indication of how well it works right on
the label the SPF number so these brands
are profiting off the fear they've
promoted about chemical sunscreens while
sneakily or maybe even unknowingly using
a less safe ingredient when they really
could have just been transparently using
autosylate instead and I'm sure a lot of
clean Beauty Brands have no idea about
this because you kind of have to be a
bit clueless about science to be a clean
Beauty brand in the first place I mean
if you look at these ingredients in the
environmental working groups database in
there in my opinion typical
pseudoscientific way they've rated
ultrasolate as higher Hazard than
butaloctal salicylate I'm assuming it's
just because octa-salate is actually an
approved chemical sunscreen that's had
more safety studies done or perhaps
maybe it's because they I wanted to be
able to give more Brands their ewg
verified label which has an application
fee of 500 and then a tiered fee
structure based on profits of course I
actually didn't realize how big a
problem this was until recently as a lot
of you probably know from my repeater
complaints I do not like mineral
sunscreens so I never really paid too
much attention to their marketing I
think they're unnecessary for most
people a lot of people are only
suffering through them and probably
getting less sun protection because of
this clean Beauty misinformation and now
that I've looked into the marketing it
turns out that a lot of clean 100
mineral chemical free sunscreens were
functionally combination or hybrid
sunscreens containing mineral and
chemical sunscreens all along and now we
have come to the part of the video where
we take a little Scenic tour through
what is in my opinion clean Beauty
hypocrisy all of the following is purely
my opinion let's start with color
science they have inactive butylactyl
salicylate high up in the ingredients
list for pretty much all of their
non-tinted sunscreens they say 100
chemical free active ingredient a lot of
sunscreen brands that use butyloftal
salicylate say this I'm letting most of
them off the hook if they don't have any
other stuff trashing chemical sunscreens
even though these EU marketing
guidelines do say all free from claims
without a good reason are unfairly
fear-mongering on their own plus since
butylactyl salicylate is acting as a
chemical sunscreen it should also count
as a dishonest claim let's skip past the
fact that zinc oxide is a chemical they
say color science has never and will
never use any chemical sunscreen actives
I guess maybe they should put legally
approved in there color science actually
highlight the reasons they don't use
chemical sunscreens and they mention
OCTA Sally specifically a bunch of times
they say You're Not Meant to use it when
you're pregnant and to use their product
that has Outlaw after sale later in it
to me mentioning pregnancy is just
particularly predatory because when
you're pregnant you are super anxious
there are so many rules and conflicting
info about what you can and can't do and
there's all these hormones going through
your body so this to me is pretty gross
they say after solid is a penetration
enhancer I think this comes from studies
that look specifically at penetration of
small molecules like herbicides and
hormones not sunscreens other Studies
have also found that regular
moisturizers do it too but again they
are using an ingredient that is so much
like octosalate in their product that it
almost definitely does the same thing a
whole bunch of these zinc sunscreen
brands have also started saying that the
FDA is asking for additional safety data
on chemical sunscreens which is true but
in a lot of other regions Regulators
have checked the safety data for the
same chemical sunscreens and approve
them it's mostly that the FDA is very
slow with sunscreen reform and has
specific requirements for for the new
test that they want and for butylock to
salicylate there is no safety data
required by the FDA because it's ducking
the regulations and it hasn't been
checked to the same extent in any other
country either if you're saying chemical
sunscreens are so dangerous then your
ingredient is worse so maybe you
shouldn't be exaggerating how dangerous
they are now most brands mentioning this
FDA stuff are talking about chemical
sunscreens in general but what's super
interesting to me is that color science
says the FDA wants extra data on 11
ingredients they list them here there's
no octa-salate but if you go to the FDA
page that they link it actually says the
FDA wants extra info on 12 ingredients
this particular page doesn't have the 12
listed but in every other list from the
FDA Ulta solid is right there so to me
this really does seem like they realize
that their ingredient is basically
octa-salate in a wig these names are
difficult to pronounce I really don't
think they can argue that after salary
it is harder to pronounce than
butylactyl salicylate like I am
struggling with that word and color
science is already really hard to
pronounce like I don't even know if I'm
saying that correctly I think it's
correct but I have been saying
colorescience and I've heard that
everywhere a whole bunch of times
harmful chemicals entering the
bloodstream spreading across the body
causing harm disrupting the endocrine
system affecting hormones causing
cellular damage there's no good evidence
that this happens in humans with
sunscreens or that even if there are
small disruptions they are anywhere near
dangerous I'm assuming they wrote this
based on those FDA blood absorption
studies but again the safety has been
assessed in a lot of other countries
chemical sunscreens including
octa-salate are potentially dangerous
toxic harsh cheap but their product is
made with wholesome ingredients also
this bit there is no evidence that zinc
oxide harms Coral zinc oxide is worse
for corals than a lot of chemical
sunscreens and this isn't just Nano zinc
oxide this is any zinc oxide because the
thing that is hurting the coral is zinc
ions this doesn't seem to be a big issue
except for maybe outliers where there
are a whole bunch of people swimming
near the coral with tons of sunscreen on
the concentrations measured at reefs is
much lower than what's required to
really damage coral and this is the case
with any sunscreen including chemical
sunscreens including oxybenzone and
octanoxate it's really just these
outlier measurements that seem to be a
problem there are issues with this data
which I will talk about in a later video
and if all this wasn't enough they also
have tried Echo salicylate in their
products as well which is like the third
triplet with his hair parted the other
way and of course the ewg also rates
this sofa than octo salad teaso so tizo
says they are free from chemical
sunscreen filters except the ones that
aren't actually approved I guess they
also have this FDA thing but at least
they say 12 chemical ingredients they
have this fun comparison table where
they show how minerals provide Superior
skin benefits and most of these are just
not true I've debunked a whole bunch of
these before I'll do a quick Speed Run
version because because most of the
brands I'll be showing repeat a lot of
these myths mineral sunscreens absorb
about 90 of incoming UV and converted to
heat just like with chemical sunscreens
the total amount of heat is
insignificant anyway it heats up your
skin less than one degree Celsius a tiny
amount of chemical sunscreen absorbs
into blood but it doesn't mean it's
harmful we have very sensitive detection
methods plus newer chemical sunscreens
are purposely designed to not absorb
into skin some people actually find
mineral sunscreens more irritating
because they're gritty and drying a lot
of sunscreens from outside the US that
are for sensitive skin use chemical
filters allergies are only a problem for
people who are allergic to those things
I am personally allergic to tuna and
eggplant if you are not I do not expect
you to stop eating them in solidarity or
anything because they are delicious
chemical sunscreens don't all burn eyes
and some people find mineral sunscreens
worse zinc oxide is actually worse for
Coral than a lot of chemical sunscreens
in that it causes harm at lower
concentrations and it's not a big issue
anyway because the concentration
measured out reefs have been much lower
than what's needed to damage coal apart
from a few outliers like I mentioned
before and of course all of these
supposed cons apply to butylactyl
salicylate as well which they are using
so again They are promoting this
misinformation about chemical sunscreens
while relying on an unregulated chemical
sunscreen to make their product work Cod
stands for contains only titanium and
zinc yeah they also say they contain no
chemical sunscreens near and they just
repeat a whole bunch of misinformation
about chemical sunscreens being bad that
is pretty much the same as tezo I wonder
if one of them actually got lazy and
copied off the other even the brand
names sound kind of the same and they're
both founded by plastic surgeons okay so
I went off and researched this and they
have the same parent company and I think
they suit cooler for copying this
particular formula with the butylactic
salicylate and in the legal document
they are just repeating all of this
misinformation in there does this count
as perjury I am not a lawyer ghost
democracy they turned the tezo table
into a bunch of essays and they added
stuff about how chemical sunscreens
directly lead to skin cancers
inflammation and irritation which is
what apparently chemical sunscreens
including oxalate which is the twin
brother of their ingredient in their
sunscreen they set up an environment in
which your skin absorbs a UV rays and
transform them into heat and the result
of this is inflammation irritation
increases your chance of skin reactions
but they also increase your chances of
exposing yourself to other illnesses
including skin cancer in extreme cases
so they've blown up the less than one
degree of heat into skin cancer somehow
I don't know do these people like not
eat hot food not wash their hands in hot
water not take hot showers like they
only take ice showers look if I sound
mad I am mad because these brands are
making products less safe with this BS
marketing and they're probably
encouraging people to expose themselves
to a lot more UV which is a known
carcinogen by making them use a
sunscreen that doesn't work as well for
no good reason and scaring them about
other sunscreens I read so many reviews
while researching this video where
people were just trying to make mineral
sunscreens work for them because this
marketing had made them feel like they
needed to use these mineral sunscreens
which of course these brands are selling
people are massively underapplying to
avoid white casts and mixing it with
stuff I even came across a brand that
uses butylactic salicylate of course and
they're actually telling people to apply
pea-sized amounts to their hands rub
their hands together and Pat it into
their body appears about half a mil you
are meant to apply a shot glass 30 mils
to your body no one is applying 60ps and
rubbing their hands together and patting
it in I don't think I'm even
exaggerating when I say clean beauty is
literally killing people there was this
survey done in 2017 in Australia and
they found that only 55 of adults agreed
that sunscreen could be used safely on a
daily basis and this is down from 61 in
2013 and 2014. 17 of adults agreed that
ingredient and sunscreen are bad for
health if used regularly and if you look
up when clean Beauty started 2017 is
quite early on in the clean Beauty wave
and this was well before Tick Tock
became this super powered flood of
misinformation and it doesn't like it's
fine because people can just use mineral
sunscreens instead as we can see from
these reviews a lot of people are going
to all these links to try to use it
they're putting I don't know 60ps and
rubbing them together and patting them
in a whole bunch of people are not going
to bother with the 60ps and they're
going to realize mineral sunscreens
aren't worth the bother chemical
sunscreens and hybrid sunscreens that
have chemical and mineral are worse for
you than the Sun and giving you skin
cancer anyway so people are just going
to go into the sun without sunscreen and
this survey is done in Australia which
has one of the highest rates of skin
cancer in the world more than 2 000
people die from skin cancer every year
here pretty much everyone in Australia
knows someone who has had part of their
face cut out because of skin cancer and
even with all of this people are getting
increasingly scared to use sunscreen and
then on top of that they these brands
are also destroying trust in the
scientific and medical institutions who
are promoting chemical sunscreens and
other life-saving things so it isn't
even just skin cancer which is already
bad enough it's other cancers infectious
diseases all of that stuff it's winding
back all of this painstaking slow
progress that's been made towards having
longer and healthier lives and there's
limited funding for health and so
governments and scientists have to waste
all this time and money on things that
we have already solved and that means
that we have less money for the things
that still need research so yeah I am
mad
all right back to light entertainment
Barbie Botanicals chemical sunscreens
apparently interfere with the Skin
Barrier what a Pity because your
sunscreen has a chemical sunscreen in it
chemical sunscreens are apparently
chemicals cooked up in a lab including
octa-salate again your chemical
sunscreens twin brother they tell you to
pay attention to the active ingredients
but apparently do not look at the
inactive ingredients chemical sunscreens
come at a cost for both you and the
environment that is kind of vaguely
threatening they conveniently list out a
bunch of chemical sunscreens including
octa-salate they say if you notice one
of these chemicals like after sale
listed in the ingredients list it's best
to keep looking they whip out the word
nasty and then they literally link two
of their sunscreens that contain
butyloftosalacylate again I don't think
chemical sunscreens are nasty but if
you're going to call them nasty maybe
don't put an even nastier ingredient in
your sunscreen say Moi this is an ewg
Affiliated brand they go part of their
clean con last year I did not make that
name up that is what they called it they
are kind of telling on themselves their
ewg verified they adhere to European
cosmetic regulations as their Baseline
would be nice if they also adhered to
those fair and honest marketing
guidelines as well they tell you to
avoid chemical sunscreen and look for
mineral sunscreens like ours of course
they do just buy our products avoid
everyone else's okay they have an
explanation in their Sun School series
and it's this diagram that we see all
the time with that like bouncy Sunshine
thing and yeah all of this is just wrong
and also kind of weirdly worded so they
say chemical sunscreens absorb skin
damaging UV rays good I guess they also
absorb potentially harmful chemicals
which isn't that good again let me
remind you they essentially use chemical
sunscreens in their products so it's
pretty irresponsible for them to be
using something that they say is harming
humans and the environment according to
them at least goddess garden you know
it's going to be good with a name like
that their sunscreens are a safe
alternative to chemical sunscreens they
they say we are very particular about
the ingredients we select for our
formulas apparently not particularly
enough to look up their actual
ingredients apparently we have the
standard myths about how natural is
better ignore the fact that nature is
constantly trying to kill us and ignore
the fact that your product that you are
trying to sell the sole purpose of it is
to prevent nature from killing you like
if nature was really that safe then your
products should not have to exist
biodegradable interestingly chemical
sunscreen actors are actually
biodegradable but minerals are not zinc
oxide doesn't break down it stays the
zinc oxide which generally isn't a
problem but if they are going to make a
claim like this it should at least be
true alright this bit is kind of
hilarious don't hire SPS usually use
chemical sunscreens often higher SPS use
chemicals to block UV rays because
higher mineral content can mean a more
whitening effect but we only use
minerals in our SPF 50 sunscreens and
we've worked hard to make them [ __ ] no
this is exactly what you're doing but in
a a less Safe Way chemical sunscreens
can also be found in the bloodstream
following use so the FDA is conducting
research to ensure chemical sunscreens
are safe for use guess which ingredient
they aren't studying and after silent is
one of the ones that absorbs into blood
so your butaloctal salicylate probably
does too you will never find chemical
actors like oxybenzone and octanoxate in
our sunscreens because our families
deserve better and our environment does
too I don't know if using an unregulated
and unstudied version of a chemical
sunscreen is any better maybe that is
what you deserve all good this brand has
gone above and beyond with their
Creative Marketing they've invented
something called the awful eight because
I guess actual alliteration is for
Chumps anyway they're just chemical
sunscreens and they're saying other
companies are green washing for having
chemical sunscreens in their products
while saying they're very friendly
because they don't have oxybenzone and
octane oxide which were the ones that
Hawaii banned and I guess the green
washing is kind of true but also they
are green washing because a lot of the
chemical sunscreens they've named are
actually less toxic for Coral than zinc
oxide especially since you have to use a
lot more zinc oxide and a product to get
the same SPF Plus on top of that of
course they are using octa-salate's
Outlaw twin honestly they are actually
really creative they say octa-salate is
like the X-Men of chemical sunscreen
ingredients it enhances Skin's
permeability and that link actually goes
back to the color signs page apparently
off to Saleh can negatively impact your
immune system and Trigger allergies and
that link goes straight back to the ewg
because of course and then there's this
whole thing which is what really really
pisses me off there's almost no point in
wearing sunscreen when the ingredients
are just as harmful as the sun you wear
sunscreen to protect your skin so why
poison it with chemicals I've done
enough ranting in this video already by
Clarity I swear this is the last one I
just wanted to mention them because they
have the standard stuff like break up
with chemical sunscreens apparently
chemical sunscreens are just too
dramatic but they also keep referencing
the ewg which is hilarious because the
ewg actually rated their sunscreens as
very bad like it's a seven it's in like
that Red Zone where your Metro I don't
know burn it and make sure your
descendants do not go nearer because I
don't know it it should just be like
heated into space so yeah stop citing
the ego they don't even like you what
are you doing this is sad thank you for
participating in my therapy session
butaloctal salicylate isn't the only SPF
booster like this it is the most
commonly used one though and it is
probably quite safe but it does
potentially open the door for maybe less
safe ingredients to be used in a similar
way most of these are the boosters that
actually absorb UV are quite similar to
other sunscreen filters but unlike with
butyloftal salicylate and off to salate
some of these have different enough
changes to their structures that you
would expect them to interact quite
differently from the proper approved
versions and some of the properly
approved versions do have some potential
environmental and health risks that are
being scrutinized so the these are kind
of slipping under the radar so I really
do think these unregulated versions
should really go through the proper
safety evaluation process and with this
very slow FDA approval process for newer
filters since 1978 there's only been I
think three sunscreen ingredients that
have been approved in the US and the
whole chemical sunscreen FDA safety
reassessment on top of all this clean
Beauty fear-mongering I expect these
sorts of ingredients will probably be
used more and more so I guess the
takeaway here is apart from the fact
that clean beauty is BS if you thought
you were using a mineral sunscreen and
it turns out that some of these
ingredients are in it maybe you've just
learned something about your skin and
how you can't really generalize chemical
sunscreen ingredients they are a really
diverse group and if you're sensitive to
a few of them it doesn't mean all of
them aren't going to work with your skin
so maybe it's worth trying out some
hybrid or chemical sunscreens thank you
for letting me get angry with you today
if you want more ranching there there is
a playlist here if you want less ranting
maybe try one of the science playlists